hello everyone my name is gautam johan
and i'm a research fellow at pine
biotech
and today i'll be discussing with you
about my research topic that is
comparative transcriptomic analysis to
understand the role of melanin in
melanoma
before jumping directly into the topic
let us first understand about melanin
and melanoma
melanin it is a term that we all have
heard before so melanin as we all know
it is a pigment that is found in most of
the organism and it determines our skin
color
our hair color and even our eye color
so
melanin is basically a pigment naturally
occurring pigment that is present
in most of the organisms and it
determines the color of our skin
our hair and even our eyes
it is produced through a process called
melanogenesis melanogenesis basically
made up of two words first is melanin
and second is genesis that is formation
so the production of melanin is called
melanogenesis and melanin is
produced in a group of specialized cells
that are called melanocytes
the main function of melanin is to
protect us against the uv radiations
and we can say that if we are more
exposed to the uv radiations there would
be more melanin production in our body
and therefore our skin would be of
darker color
uh basically if
somebody has a darker skin or a darker
comp
complex
then
his or her skin would be having more
melon and that is actually a very good
thing cause we'll be learning further
in the in the further slides that having
more melanin
or having a darker skin is actually
beneficial because it is it reduces the
chances of you developing a melanoma
thus
more melanin production or darker skin
the better it is to protect yourself
from melanoma
so
next if i talk about melanoma so
melanoma is one of the types of the skin
cancer
and it is the most serious type of the
skin cancer that develops in the
melanocytes melanocytes we discussed
earlier that the granules in which the
melanin is produced
so it is the most serious type of skin
cancer there are other types of skin
cancer as well but it melanoma is the
most serious type of skin cancer and as
you can see in this picture it will look
something similar to this
initially you might think of it as a
mole but it when it starts spreading
uh it obviously would not look like a
mole anymore
so melanoma is basically
the most serious kind of
skin cancer and
one of the risk factors that i told you
is having a fairer skin
yes if you have a fairer skin the
chances of you developing melanoma is
very high so it is one of those risk
factors risk factor
we all know risk factor basically means
anything that would increase your chance
of having that particular disease thus
having a fairer skin
would
increase your chance of developing
melanoma
so
now that we've learned about melanin and
melanoma let us
talk about our topic that is about the
transcriptomic
analysis of the role of the melanin in
melanoma
so
if i talk about the human epidermal
melanocytes or the hems
they provide a critical protection
against the skin cancer
um again skin cancer are of different
types but here we'll talk about uh
melanoma
uh it protects us against the sunburns
and photo aging so they definitely play
a very important role in
skin cancer or melanoma
so in this
research project i took two samples
uh from the darker skin people and two
from the lighter skin people and then
compared them
to understand about the different genes
that are expressed in the darker skin
and lighter skin and as i discussed
earlier that the darker skin people
would be having more melanin production
in them
thus their chance of developing skin
cancer is lesser
and the lighter skin would be having
very less melanin production in them
thus their
chance of developing
skin cancer or melanoma would be higher
so this was the basis of my study this
was the basis on which i started about
my research
project
now if i talk about the methodology from
the data set that i got i initially ran
the rna sequencing pipeline
to so to get the expected gene count
table
this was my result that i got a lot of
results but the important one was the
gene uh
expected count table after which i moved
on to the pca
and finally i developed
a pipeline for the differential gene
expression
and through which i got very good
results which i'll show you in the later
slides and
that helped me to interpret the level of
expression of the genes
and
how those genes were expressing in the
darker versus the lighter skin people
so
this was the first plot that i got after
my differential gene expression pipeline
in this
this is basically a volcano plot that
shows us the levels of the gene
expression
the red color genes that you screen c on
your screen is the genes that are having
higher level of expression in them
on the x axis we have log to fold change
and on the y axis we have the p adjusted
value
so
we have a variety of genes the red ones
are
uh
more differentially expressed than the
black ones and
the point that we see on the x-axis if
it's
on the left or on the negative side of
the x-axis it would be
down regulated gene and on the positive
side or the right side of the x-axis
there would be
up-regulated genes
another graph that we got from this was
uh about the mean of the normalized
counts against the log fold change
in this also we see the blue dots are
the ones that show high level of
expression the gray one
where the
normal level of expression we can say
and blue ones were definitely higher
also in this
um all the values above zero like the
positive values will be for the up
regulated gene and the negative values
would be definitely for the
down regulated genes
this was another important uh result uh
that we can you know interpret from this
graph
next we had
uh the gene ontology enrich pathways
in which we can see different uh
pathways that are present against
the
gene ratio on the x-axis
so
we see the different pathways like the
cell junction assembly the sodium ion
transport skin development positive
regulation of the
cell junction assembly so these are the
top 20 pathways that were present and
the red dot signifies that it's having a
higher level of expression and the dot
value basically shows
or the circle would show that
how many number of genes are present for
example if i talk about the cell
junction assembly we can see it would be
having around eight genes and its
pre-adjusted value
is
nearly about point zero three point zero
two and it is highly differentially
expressed
so
this was the type of interpretation that
would be
that we would be getting from
these graphs and
next
what i would be doing
uh is basically taking the genes
that are quite highly expressed in the
melanoma cells and then i'll be
comparing it with the fairer and darker
skin to see whether those genes that are
involved in the melanoma or the melanoma
pathway are
highly expressed or
you know highly
present in the darker skin or lighter
skin and then i'll be concluding with my
work
stating that these genes have this much
level of expression in the darker skin
and this much in the lighter skin
obviously those genes would be having if
if a person has melanoma and definitely
those genes would be the genes that
would be present in a less quantity in
the darker skin and
probably in more quantity
in the lighter scale but when i'll do
that analysis that would be the
end of my work and
then i'll be concluding my work
thank you i hope you understood this
presentation and the work i did till now
and i'll be continuing it further
thank you